okay and how long have you owned your  own business nine years and how and how  long have you been making six figures or  more on the last three okay why do you  need a man making six figures um because  i'm finding out that the guys that i  date that's not is not working out what  does it have to do with money because i  feel like i need a god that i can  respect and admire and i'm a [ __ ]  ambition and i want a guy that has that  drive too and when he doesn't i find  myself you know encouraging like hey  babe you can do this and you can do that  a man that doesn't make six figures can  meet those qualifications  i know a lot of driven guys that make  70k a year that's great 60 like this is  still above average  exactly like the qualifications  that she just listed off a man does not  have to make six figures to beat those  qualifications why do you only respect  him if he makes that much